the story we got from the daily signal
three arrested after antifa clashes with
Armenian parents at California school
board meeting this is uh significant
regular people are saying no over and
over and over again we've got the Bud
Light effect you've got Target and now
you've got parents showing up saying you
know we politely requested that these
books not be in our schools now we're
protesting then the far left shows up
these extremists and start attacking
parents yeah now you've got clashes this
is this is where things get crazy
because if you've got regular guy
wearing hoodie and jeans being like look
man I don't know why they gave my kid
that book and then some crackpot Fallout
extremist shows up those regular people
are not going to vote no they're not and
they're now going to vote they're going
to the the regular people are going to
vote and and I was going a different
direction the uh
I'm gonna use a word the left loves
especially when they deploy their Dei
and ESG initiative they love the term
stakeholder so tpack I did a panel on
debanking because our fund experienced
it because we did some work in the
defense sector ammo et cetera et cetera
and we were debanked from a couple of
Banks and one of the words they love
they've changed uh the nomenclature for
who's invested from shareholder to
stakeholder right so the stakeholder
according to these big Banks like svb
that went under and the Really woke
Banks
um First Republic out in California they
consider the homeless guy sleeping in
the ATM Lobby a stakeholder that's right
right
but in this scenario
antifa whomever they were they have no
stake in this whatsoever no stake
whatsoever so the parents the kids the
teachers the administrators the school
board local elected officials you can
argue they're all stakeholders I hate
the stakeholder term anyway
but the radical leftists who showed up
had no stake in this they were showing
up simply to be instigators and what
they everybody's trying to make this
about Armenian Americans and this and no
these are just parents who've been who
are fed up they've had enough you saw it
you know not far away from here Loudoun
County and uh here these people said
enough's enough and I think that's the
way and I'm not trying to get anybody's
head but I think that's how many of
these parents saw it it wasn't where a
certain uh uh you know demographic and
and this is politically ideological and
we're opposed to them because we're
conservative and they're no I think
they're just basically saying these are
our kids what the hell business do you
have here and why are you coming here to
disrupt the way we want our kids taught
and the way we want to parent and as
we've seen I mean you guys so Tim you've
been out there and in the streets with
this stuff they instigate they instigate
they instigate and they've always gotten
away with it and this time they didn't
they just had Fed Up parents who had
enough who wanted to protect their kids
and I think you're going to see more and
more of this because people are just
look you could do a lot of things don't
come after people's kids when you you
start coming after people's kids bad
things happen yeah it makes people
desperate like create like you see the
mother bear the female Bear yeah it'll
just go sight completely blood like it's
not even bloodlust like it wants to hurt
it wants to protect protect that child
and it will annihilate anything if
you're well-meaning you see a little cup
you want right it's just you want to pet
it look at it if you're well meaningful
I think that a lot of times people in
this movement this political movement
the trans movement or whatever you want
to call it are for them they believe
they are well-meaning right but it
doesn't matter if you're if people find
a threat towards their children so you
need to understand the people
right
these are these are people who are
intentionally targeting children with
overt adult content that's right Matt
Walsh the daily wire we'll get more in
depth in this after we wrap up this
story did an expose where he found this
this rubber stamping of procedures of
section procedures because these
companies are getting tons of money for
it they are not well-meaning they are
selfish egotistical violent narcissists
who are in a cult I just rewatched the
music video of will convert your
children you remember that oh yeah
welcome they're your children like
smiling and like and like yo you can't
just joke and say that out loud they're
not joking they said they were joking
like a week later or two weeks later
after the fact you're like I was just we
were just playing around like you just
told people you were going to convert
their children and so that's how they do
it they said they're gonna get their
friends they're going to bring me back
yeah you there's nothing you can do to
stop it you can't control what your kids
see like the boys they're talking about
giving your children access to adult
content to indoctrinate them yeah
they're doing it now yeah and and so I'm
surprised it took this long for parents
to to realize and to be active and for
the record it was a San Francisco Gay
Men's Choir who has made this video
where it was like a bunch of guys
singing about how they're going to
convert your children
I mean whoa but listen it's not a new
the parents are fed up now because the
bad guys the groomers call them what you
will are getting closer physically
closer in proximity to the kids when I
left law enforcement go back to the
early mid 2000s I worked quite a bit
right before I left and then after with
the national Center for missing and
exploited children and I wish I could
unsee some of the imagery and some of
the case files I saw that I wouldn't get
into here it wouldn't be appropriate but
what I will tell you is this has been
around for a long time
NAMBLA the North American man boy love
Association they skirted laws for years
because their first amendment protected
right they said well we're simply
disseminating information on Nations
that have lacks laws for sex with kids
or uh if you want to protect kids don't
go to these nations that have child sex
tourism that's how they get around it
but if you really want to get into their
psyche there's a great book it was
written probably in the early to mid 90s
by an FBI agent the guy's name this one
the bureau actually did some good work
and wasn't a political persecution Squad
I believe the guy thing was Bob gamer
and it's called the last undercover and
it's about he's he's pretty much spent
he was an anomaly he pretty much spent
his entire career undercover he wasn't a
guy that did field work for a while then
did it for a little bit and came back he
just had a knack for it and this guy did
everything from biker gangs to Lakota
Nostra his last one was embedding with
NAMBLA and he embedded as a trust fund
guy who was a pedophile and the things
they would do like back when there was a
mall at Herald Square in Manhattan they
would congregate a group of these
pedophiles these men from like their
mid-30s to their 70s would go to the
mall in Herald Square on the second
floor and watch the kids come in after
school and pick their targets and this
has been going on but you couldn't we
tried we went after NAMBLA and Nick back
went after enamel in the bureau and uh
Homeland Security investigations HSI is
very good at this one of the best in the
world uh we joked about Canada the RCMP
has really talented child sex crimes
investigators but these guys are smart
and the scary thing is they're often
well funded and they don't fit a profile
anybody in this room could fit the
profile anybody in a restaurant can fit
the profile it's really difficult to
tell who they are but they are proactive
and they are some of the worst Predators
you'll ever see now what they're doing
they've been so emboldened for so long
by knowing how to play the system and
knowing how to frustrate law enforcement
that they've getting close they've
gotten closer and closer and now they're
comfortable physically getting into the
schools becoming teachers becoming
administrators now
I'm not going to go off on conspiracy 10
into my Global pedophile networks and
all yeah there are definitely Global
child sex trafficking networks this is a
law enforcement established fact right
isn't Maxwell in jail because of that
she's 100 of you obviously no I'm saying
that what I'm saying is I don't think
you know Hillary Clinton's personally
abducting kids and the podesta brothers
are helping her Advance picking the kids
up and we've seen those things too I'm
not going to go down that road but there
are definitely child sex trafficking
networks around the world we know this
right in fact one of the groups that
that actually has helped are the Mexican
cartels because they know it's bad for
business right if you talk to federal
law enforcement or intelligence
Community they'll tap the cartels for
information on some of these Tech traps
because cartels don't look they want to
sell their drugs right and they'll
traffic adult women in prostitution but
they know kids are really bad for
business that's when we send special
operators down there to start killing
people if they start abducting kids to
solve the problem but they've gotten
very bold because they've gotten away
with it for so long they haven't been
prosecuted now they are in the schools
that's not conspiratorial they're being
handcuffed and pulled out and you're not
seeing the stories because the left-wing
media doesn't want to validate what the
right's been saying but exactly but I
think you're talking about the uh the
super liminal and the issue at play now
is the subliminal well I think they go
hand them hand there's both well hand in
hand but this story is they pretend to
be activists they use cover of media so
I I referred to one journalist as likely
a pedophile because she was covering up
overt pedophilic actions you've got this
one teacher now I think her what's her
name Sarah Bonner or something like that
in Illinois
instructing young children on how to use
adult anonymous gay sex apps right why
would a teacher go to children and say
read this there's only one answer but I
don't see that as subliminal I see that
as overt that's over what I'm saying is
that when you get activists in the media
defending it saying it's it's you hate
gay people that is the is the subliminal
that is the manipulation right where
they are taking control of the machine I
tell you if there is no pushback and I I
don't see this becoming a reality
reality but they will try to legalize
this stuff yeah
they will but to your point Tim about
about these these journalists and all
and you see them as pedophiles
themselves you're 100 right here's
here's here's a case that that isn't a
pedophilia case but it I think it's a
good parallel I don't know if you guys
remember a lawyer named Lynn Stewart she
was a lawyer for Abdul Rahman the blind
Sheikh he was the guy behind the First
World Trade Center bombing in 93. right
when that wasn't too devastating and for
years federal law enforcement knew that
she was he was her client but they knew
she was assisting aiding a betting and
she would always stand behind her law
license and privilege well finally they
had enough and they uh you know they
knew it was the crime fraud exemption
right they knew what she was doing they
were able to get surveillance in the
federal holding facility saw that he was
giving her kites you know prison notes
she was passing information on to these
terrorists enabling his Terror Network
and she eventually was was conducted
prosecuted et cetera et cetera it's the
same thing these journalists who are
sympathetic to this are doing they're
enabling it and they should be
prosecuted as such I just looked up well
Ophelia well that that's a very very
difficult line it's one thing if there's
an active terrorist giving instruction
to a terror Network and you're acting as
a courier for the for that illegal
information and if you're giving but see
here sorry I disagree with you if you're
giving them cover by using your law
license to Shield how do we know these
journalists aren't doing the same how do
we know the journalist engages in an
illegal activity by all means prosecute
them if a journalist has a disgusting
opinion fire them and make make what
they do Unthinkable but what I'm saying
is most normal human beings most normal
human beings would not be permissive of
such heinous Behavior unless they had a
stake in it somehow right right so I
think there's probable cause there yeah
or at least there isn't Reasonable
Suspicion to start looking deeper to get
to the PC to get the warrants yeah
agreed yeah yeah uh you you made this
point about people infiltrating the
public school system and I think that's
very important because what the left in
the dominant media culture has made very
clear to the American people is that if
you are someone who wants to abuse
children as long as you're using they
them pronouns or the pronouns of the
opposite sex they will treat anyone who
regards you with suspicion as a bigoted
person who shouldn't be listened to
that's right that's right I just looked
up philia this is a lot of like word
play that they're do that people have
been doing pedophilia philia is a type
of love from Greece ancient Greece and
it's the type of love that translates as
friendship the love of friendship uh
philia it's fine but arrows hemophilia
yeah Eros is love sexual love now these
people are pederotic they're not
pedophilic they might be both but you
got to call them pederosts at the very
least like they're it's about the the
it's not about I mean it is weird for a
grown adult to be friends with a
nine-year-old kid that's not their son
but it is it's the erotic love that's
the problem you know what I had a I had
a former Federal prosecutor good guy who
did these trainings at Nick Mack who
would drum that into everybody's head
they're not pedophiles they're
betterists he would say exactly what you
just said because he wanted to draw that
distinction it goes back to a lot of
what we say right in in conservative or
or libertarian media that that language
does matter don't let the left own the
narrative don't let them create new
terms he was adamant about that so you
spot omelette oh that's good who was
that that did that it was uh I forget
the guy's name he we had a bunch of
trainers I forget his name he was an FBI
agent back when the bureau was good and
then he was a federal prosecutor I got
to dig it up for you yeah man love is
not love there are many different types
of love and that is super important
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time